[Music]
hi everyone its charlie they dropped the
first official teaser for The Witcher
Netflix TV series which is going to be
premiering later this year they're going
to comic-con where they'll probably drop
the first official trailer so we'll just
break down all these teasers and explain
what's going on most of you are probably
at least a little familiar with the
series because you played the games or
you've actually read the books too
the series itself will be based on the
books the games are actually a sequel
series to the books so while trying to
differentiate that as I start talking
about all these teasers I'll be doing
videos for all the episodes when it
drops later this year that's gonna be in
December I'll just explain what the
schedule is gonna be so no worries if
you're brand new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the Witcher
videos when we get a little bit closer
I'll find some giveaway to do for the
series to either for the books or for
the games or something like that really
important stuff The Witcher Netflix
Comic Con panel is gonna be on Friday
July 19th in about two weeks two weeks
from this Friday so it's right around
the corner the actual episodes won't
premiere till around December December
was the last report we got but it's
gonna basically be the very end of the
year there'll be eight episodes in the
first season they haven't said how many
seasons they're planning on going for
but right now I'm just assuming
somewhere between four and five and
they'll just cover everything from the
book series because of how old Siri
looks and because she's a big part of
this series I'll explain where I think
the story actually picks up and I'll do
a quick summary of the books that I
think season one will cover which are
both the end of sword of Destiny and
then blood of elves blood of elves is
actually the first real big novel that
was written sword of Destiny is kind of
a prequel to those events so because
it's only eight episodes I think in the
same way the Game of Thrones does some
brief flashbacks to stuff like Robert's
rebellion stuff that perceives the
events of the first book I think The
Witcher series is gonna do the same
thing where you largely pick up during
blood of elves and then you just deal
with a lot of the backstory for the
characters and how they got to where
they were in flashbacks the official
tagline for the series sometimes the
worst monsters are the ones we create is
a reference to a couple of the things
that happen during those prequels
stories so that's mostly how you get
into the back story of where ciri comes
from why she's so important to the
series with the relationship between all
the main characters and the villains are
so that I think they're gonna cover
during flashback since
season one there's a couple really
spoilery things that they reveal later
in the series from those earlier stories
so I think that will cover that across
the series because like you didn't get
those big game of Thrones flashbacks
telling you the origin of Jon Snow till
way later in the game of Thrones series
but just based on how old Siri looks in
this I'm guessing that this picks up
with blood of elves early on in the
series Geralt meets Siri a couple
different times and their relationship
begins but he doesn't realize
immediately the first time they meet how
important she's going to be that doesn't
happen till later
that seems like an might wind up
happening towards the middle or the end
of season 1 just based on how they plot
out certain arcs like you pick up with
Geralt do you explain who he is what his
relationships are what his profession in
his trade are Monster Hunter for hire
you explained why he does the things
that he does he is a very special code
he doesn't want to kill intelligent
monsters and non violent ones so
sometimes the people that hire him to
kill monsters are worse than the
monsters themselves one of his biggest
nicknames is the butcher of Glavine he
got that name because a bunch of
terrible people hired him to kill a non
violent monster he found out that the
people were worse he killed them and
then was run out of town and given that
name because this is the first round of
teasers of course we're not revealing
everything about the main villains of
the series which basically Emperor Amir
in Villa forts the sorcerer you don't
really see him anywhere in any of this
material so I don't know how big vilgum
force is going to be during season 1 but
because the way most of these big
fantasy stories are played out they'll
probably reveal this big threat of
nilfgaard and then eventually reveal who
Emperor Mir is sort of a Darth Vader
Emperor situation you eventually meet
the Emperor but not right away at the
beginning of this story so we might not
meet Emperor Mir till a little bit later
and I don't think that they would reveal
his complete backstory and how he's
connected to ciri right away
like I said the same way the game of
thrones didn't immediately reveal how
Rhaegar Targaryen and Lyanna stark were
connected to Jon Snow the story of The
Witcher series is very different but
there are a couple similar tropes that
it trades on where you have surprise
special child that's the daughter of a
couple really special people if you
haven't read the book series one of the
biggest surprises though is that the
books are largely about series story and
Geralt is just a really big character
that so I have a feeling that they might
have changed that a little bit for the
TV series so that you spend more time
following Geralt because obviously the
video game series spends all of its time
following Geralt and all the other
characters are just part of his story so
there will be some minor changes in the
way they plot out the TV series because
they are leaning hard on Henry Cavill to
market this series as they should but
he's not even the biggest character in
the books it's actually about series so
I wouldn't be surprised if there were a
couple twists like that during this
story where there are a couple episodes
where you spend more time following
series than you do with Geralt but a lot
of that doesn't really happen until ciri
gets older and she starts to develop her
powers she's way more powerful than
Geralt because she has the elder blood
in part of the reason why everyone wants
to get their hands on her is because of
this big prophecy that Emperor Amir is
trying to fulfill with the help of his
sorcerer Villa Forte's who's sort of the
rasputin's like character that gives
emperor Amir the idea in the first place
so it's not like everyone's trying to
get ciri because they want ciri they
just want her elder blood Villa Force
wants to impregnate her and then use the
fetus from that pregnancy to take her
power for himself and première wants
that power to but also in a larger sense
he's trying to conquer the known world
so there's a lot of stuff going on
ciri is still very young during the
course of this series so a lot of that
won't play out till later seasons but
you can make all the game of thrones Jon
Snow special blood Melisandre shadow
baby jokes that you want virgin
No
good one of the other captions that
Henry Cavill tweeted out here is Gwynn
blood that just means the white wolf in
elder speech a lot of people refer to
Geralt as the white wolf the actual
symbol for the series or that they're
using for the logo for the series is
just the three symbols that are using to
represent each of these main characters
but obviously like I said they're not
really including the villains in all
this but in a lot of these different
pictures they keep referring to destiny
bringing the three of them together but
you can see the way this symbol looks
you have the white wolf looking out over
the other two symbols in addition to the
deeper symbolic value that each of the
separate symbols have the white wolf
symbol looking out over the other two in
being bound to the other two is
representative of their destinies being
intertwined in him always looking out
over yennefer and ciri
the Obsidian star is the pendant that
yennefer wears around her neck it looks
a little bit different during the game
series but it's the mark of her craft it
just represents her character then the
symbol of the bird that they're using to
represent ciri is actually cereal which
is actually elder speech for swallow it
translates directly to swallow but it's
also the name of her witcher sword that
she gets later in the book series called
cereal she's given this very special
sword like Geralt has his special
witcher swords so the actual symbol that
she carries around in the games is a
little bit different but because the
name of her very special witcher sword
means swallow in elder speech they're
just using the swallow in the TV series
to represent her character ciri looks a
little bit older than i think she
actually is during the events of this
series she's actually being played by
this young girl so I'm guessing that
they'll start her Witcher training some
time maybe during season two but I would
be surprised if it happens during season
one speaking of which her swords a lot
of you are asking why Geralt doesn't
have both of his two swords that he has
during most of the games and for the
most part he actually just uses his
regular steel sword on the monsters that
he kills he only needs the silver sword
when he's fighting werewolves or very
special monsters and in a lot of the
books he only walks around with the one
sword the special silver sword he
usually winds up keeping holstered on
his horse Roche at most times so he
doesn't actually walk around with it on
his back like he does during the game
series all the time the games actually
retconning a really huge moment at the
end of the book series that winds up
being really spoilery so we probably
don't need to talk about it here if
you've ever played that first Witcher
game there's a couple opening game
cinematics that explain exactly what
they retcon about the end of the book
series in order to allow Geralt story to
continue it kind of be like if they try
to develop a video game series for Game
of Thrones set after the events of A
Song of Ice and Fire
so like at the end of that story you see
Jon Snow riding north of the wall they
would have to retcon some things in
order to explain why he would come back
south of the wall and why his adventure
would continue but one of the good
things about the video game series
particularly The Witcher 3 and some of
the earlier big cinematics is that they
do flashback to events that happened
during the book series so I will include
those flashback scenes and talk about
them when they're relevant to whatever
is happening in episodes or during the
trailers universe relationship in the
early parts of the story where this
series is going to take place is kind of
weird now he appears in every single
book their destinies are intertwined
they've gotten down and dirty several
times but they don't always like each
other there are times when she gets
really pissed off at him because he'll
just rush off for like a couple years to
go kill monsters and go on adventures
then come back right before Geralt meets
ciri for the first time they are an
adventure together so I don't know if
they'll be together when Geralt meets
ciri for the first time during this
series but like I said a lot of this
stuff will be dealt with in flashbacks a
lot of the early overarching story like
the really big mythology will be
dedicated to ciri trying to learn more
about her backstory about what it means
that she has this crazy powerful elder
blood within her what the truth about
her parents are because at the beginning
of the series she believes that both of
her parents are dead her grandmother is
still alive and she's the queen of
sintra but her grandmother does not tell
her the truth about who she really is
Geralt is mostly dedicated to taking
care of her and once he sort of gets
tied up in this larger big plot around
ciri that becomes a bigger part of his
story even though yennefer is gerelds
great love and their destinies are
intertwined with each other
she's also seeking a way to get rid of
the curse of her order because when
women become sorceress within the world
of The Witcher series they're barren so
what a very personal level she wants to
find a way to eventually be able to have
children again but you have all these
wars you
this crazy prophecy swirling around Siri
they get in the way of that so obviously
that's her big arc through the series
hopefully that explains a little bit
about what's going to be going on at the
beginning of the series with the main
characters obviously they're gonna be
more teasers before a comic-con happens
and then there'll be a really big
trailer but like I said episodes
probably not dropping til the beginning
or the middle of December so post all
your reactions in the comments below and
if you have any really big questions
that you want me to do bonus videos for
just let me know in the comments but
there'll be a whole bunch of stuff
happening around comic-con in a couple
weeks so no worries it's gonna be really
cool stuff wait wait for everything
click here for my spider-man far from
home post credits scene video and click
here for my Avengers endgame post
predestine video thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]